Hola buenas tardes Muchas gracias por el
espacio
en la región
tenemos todavía muchos derechos a
conquistar
tenemos sí reconocimientos de derechos
en países como por ejemplo Uruguay
Argentina chile Brasil
Costa Rica México Cuba pero la mayoría
de los países los otros países no tienen
aún derechos reconocidos legalmente esto
significa que nos queda un desafío muy
grande por para seguir adelante para
luchar y en realidad para poder ser
porque las personas de la comunidad
lgbtqi más somos personas que queremos
ser somos personas que queremos gozar de
nuestros derechos humanos y en realidad
eso es todo lo que se pide obviamente
necesitamos Marcos legales para el
reconocimiento y el respeto de los
derechos y la no discriminación y en
contra de la violencia
precisamente hablando de la violencia
Brasil es uno de los países con más
altas tasas de homicidios de personas
lgbt y Cuba que lo atribuye usted
Bueno ahí hay un en realidad yo le
llamaría
travesticidios
o
asesinatos por odio crímenes de odio
verdad Exacto exacto y ahí tiene que ver
también ahí hay una interseccionalidad
que se está dando a lo largo de
latinoamérica y el Caribe y es esa
interseccionalidad entre
aquellos movimientos que tienen
discursos de odio en general movimientos
religiosos Ultra religiosos ultras
conservadores de Iglesias
específicamente neopentecostales unidas
muchas veces al poder político que está
en contra de los derechos humanos de
hecho hablando de Brasil tuvimos El
ejemplo en Brasil cuando bolsonaro ASUME
la presidencia lo primero que hace es ir
a una iglesia neopentecostal
para recibir la bendición la mayoría de
los ministros de bolsonaro fue de
bolsonaro fueron ministros
pastores
neopentecostales De hecho hay una
bancada evangelista en el parlamento en
el congreso brasileño Y eso se repite en
menor o mayor dimensión en diferentes
países de latinoamérica